this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so I am the last speaker of
the session and I'll dress myself for
those who don't know me I'm Elena
vitamin yoga and faculty at the soils
and crop Sciences section and pond
biology section here at Cornell and what
I'm going to talk today about is about
using synchrotron x-ray fluorescence
microscopy I'll refer to it as XRF as an
imaging and high-precision phenotyping -
for studies of my knowledge and from
their studies and I'll talk today mainly
about iron - micronutrient Iowa
recruited copper because that's what we
study in a lab and also because of the
relevance of these elements for the
future food security and human health
just any briefly what I do today after a
really short introduction providing the
rationale for studies of iron and copper
for my status and wealth I'll briefly
introduce the basics of salford on x-ray
fluorescence microscopy and the
relevance of this technology for studies
of my knowledge and from the stylus and
then in the last part I'll show you some
examples from my lab which demonstrate
how a seraph is used for us to
understand the function of the illegal
pet a transporter or bt3 in iron from a
stylus and the whole pathway exposed a
regulatory path 5007 set 1 regulated
pathway in copper camila status and
relationship between copper and plant
fertility and again the studies are done
mainly in Arabidopsis but i'll continue
with some crop species so as many of you
appreciate providing the enough food for
the growing food for the growing wealth
population is one of them top challenges
of the 21st century and even today after
a billion people though in world go to
bed hungry they consume less than 2,000
calories per day and these are people
mainly in the developing countries that
you can see from this map but and in
this countries people mainly because of
their resource poor they mainly confined
to plant-based food and so these
plant-based food the staple crops which
are grown and use the discounters mainly
rice or in some case of sweet
in terms of all in the concentration of
nutrients and minerals such as iron
copper and zinc and so in addition to
consuming fewer than 2,000 calories per
day people in these countries they
suffer from so-called hidden Congress
which was the term coined by Roswell
sheared carnality in v8 to reflect the
nutrient deficiency associated health
disorders for example many of you know
and many of you probably know that iron
deficiency anemia is one of the most
prevalent attritional disorder and it
affects more than 30 percent of the
world's population and actually it is
responsible for up to a million deaths
annually and again if you look in this
map these are people which are living in
developing countries and again people
these countries are confined mainly to
plant-based food and so one of the ways
have to combat this malnutrition is to
buy a fortified crops with nutrients and
with minerals and this is emerges as a
one of the sustainable approaches how to
deal with malnutrition what's happening
here okay so copper deficiency in humans
is not as widespread as iron deficiency
however copper deficiency in soils can
really dramatically decrease a crop
productivity
well it's significantly affect one
fertility and wheat and in total its
sufferers apparently with the most from
corporal deficiency
and so and those deficiency like iron
deficiency in the soil and copper
deficiency and so and when it's actually
a zinc deficiency occurs mainly in
alkaline soils here in the map you can
see it call it as boom and this alkaline
and also natural soils they defy more
than 30 percent of the arable land right
and so if we really wanna sort of meet
the challenge of providing more
increasing food production by 70 percent
in the next 40 years and also if you
want to make sure that we are able to
buy a fortified edible parts of of
plants with nutrients really need to
know how plants have crops deal with
their environment in certain environment
in the limitation of micronutrients in
the environment and so it comes down to
knowledge of the transport system so we
need to know how transporters which
transporters and which regulators or
those transporters are responsible for
moving elements under you know under
deficiency condition from the soil into
the root how this animals which
transfers how this elements are
distributed in the plant where you load
it into the edible tissues how they are
reabsorbed for example from leaves and
moved to things such as seeds and in
that regard x-ray fluorescent microscopy
to measures like really a powerful tool
which allows us to identify knowledge
ease and characterized genes which
involved in Merrell newton commerce data
for example the reason why XRF is so
useful and can be useful because
normally in many cases disruption of
genes encoding transporters or
regulators of the transporters will
release to the to the to changes in the
distribution of the spatial distribution
of elements in in a plant in a tissue or
actually and subcellular lee and so one
can use it just use XRF to compare the
wild-type tissue rest of the mutant
issue and see whether the changes of the
special distribution occur or not and
here this is almost a classical example
for all marabou barillo lab showing arab
adopts this wild-type seed and iron
distribution in a wild pepsi and this is
a mutant for the vacuole or iron
transporter and against a mutant seed
and you can see that the pattern of iron
distribution significantly changes and
of course combining other functional
genomic approaches where one can infer
what are the gene function
so how xref help was XRF restore so xref
is imaging technique which allows you to
visualize the spatial distribution of
elements in a sample at the different
resolution scales and really in a
nutshell very simplistically XRF is
based on the detection of secondary
arrays or recall it fluorescence which
are emitted by atoms
of the sample when the sample itself is
arrested through with x-ray the reader
high-energy x-rays that are generated at
a synchrotron and the really cool
feature about this technique is that
each element emits very specific energy
fingerprint and what it allows you it
allows you to map the distribution of
specific and form of the distribution of
particular element in a in a sample and
here the concept the fight by the
distribution analysis of different
elements as you can see calcium copper
zinc and iron in the lead and that has
been done simultaneously so basically
the the advantages of using XRF over
other imaging technique well first of
all it's incredibly sensitive right so
we can visualize micronutrients such as
copper which is present in plants and
really I mean it basically single digits
ppm and inverters even below ppm values
we can still do that also the excellent
feature to us of this technique and to
many is that it's not destructive so you
don't really need to prepare samples
well depending on the resolution you
want to study so you can just take you
what we do in a logistically if go to
the synchrotron in which we look at the
elements which is amazing it's very high
spatial resolution and we can analyze
pretty much all elements of the periodic
table and for us important elements are
copper iron and we also leaning more
toward things so how this technique
helped us so so we were wondering we are
working on a transporter called
oligopeptide transporter which was
initially identified in the gary Spacey
lab and it has been known that pocket is
free I'll refer to it as a PT 3 or
equilateral sport is somehow involved an
iron from their status but the substrate
of the transporter was unknown and the o
PT 3 itself the mutant has very
intriguing properties of which I'll just
wanna highlight one leaves over the
Apogee 3 mutant accumulate a significant
election amount of iron compared to the
wild type but here's the seeds of the
mutant contains significantly less
than the wild-type it was unusual
because typically sees get their
minerals from leaves and you would be
expecting that if leaves have so much
iron then seals would have so much iron
but yet it didn't happen and so to
understand like what's going on with
iron in the leaves we decided to use XRF
we want to see what maybe iron is this
is distributed differently in the leaf
of the mutant verse of the wild-type and
we collaborated with merle oberon on and
what we found we found that actually
Iowa is trapped in the vasculature of
the leaf of the mutants so what you're
looking here is the iron distribution in
the wild-type and it's mainly you know
it gets evenly distributed but with this
main localization in vasculature but
then when you look at them a leaf of pt3
mutant you can see that iron is
highlighted in this minor way okay so
it's trebs there so it's already led us
to the idea well I won't just cannot be
renewable I so that's why it's so high
in leaf and it's so low in seed and of
course we moved on to see well vascular
consists of xylem and the form
xylem that's the the westcoast issue
which delivers minerals from the root
and into the chute but then floor is the
tissue which is responsible for
mobilizing minerals and delivering
minerals from the sources such as the
leaves to think such as C so we analyzed
the iron concentration in xylem and the
phloem set and we found that actually
the xylem step hyper accumulates iron
while the form in the mutant has
significantly less iron so basically
what we are looking here is iron in the
xylem okay
and so next question was okay well
that's that's the mutant for pg3 so what
a PT 3 is doing and so the next step was
well we have to know where the opposite
localized it's an asylum is it in the
floor and because that can tell us what
it does is it's moving iron from the
xylem and then the Newton high
calculates it in the xylem or it somehow
moves iron from desire into the floor
and so it cannot slow the
to the floor and so just simplify the
story basically we found that repeat III
is localized to the floor
so the floor transporter and mutation of
which leads to the decreased
concentration of iron in this fluid and
then the final surface area of the cake
was actually finding that PT 3 is
actually an iron transporter and we
collaborators of you girls in arose from
USDA here and we showed together that
Apogee 3 van is well what you're looking
here is all sides and of us all sides so
we did some uptake studies in xenops all
sides and so a PT 3 is actually
localizers to the plasma membrane and it
can in turn or both sides and in Abydos
s photo class and it can move iron into
the also itself so what you see here
over time or PT 3 is black bar and you
can see that it has PT 3 expressing also
itself contain more iron than control
non expressing cells so basically this
helped us to understand
so basically accelerate was sort of the
first step forward to understand what's
happening to the to the opt three mutant
and why the Newton white a high
percolates so much iron in the leaf it
can move it into the seeds and basically
it's because the iron is strapped in the
vasculature and of course it's have to
combine extra refers other techniques
what we have done to fully characterize
a gene function and so what we sort of
hope for we hope data PT 3 and it's
homologs from crops skipped species can
be used for biofortification because a
PT 3 is responsible for loading of iron
into the seeds but that's next step and
now I sort of switch gears to copper and
again just to reiterate the point that
while copper is not as copper deficiency
is not as I spread for humans for the
plants it can be detrimental and in fact
well I teach mineral nutrition and I
teach any class that well hopper is
needed for fertility and we know that in
a field right so you can see a Naveed
we've grown on the really low copper is
infertile and you know and yeah but then
we never knew why popper is needed and
so and but however copper is toxic
together as I release toxic and
accumulate in excess so plant have to
really try to regulate copper from their
status to make sure that it has enough
you know to prevent efficiency but also
avoid toxicity and so this regulation in
the plant is achieved by the
transcription factor which belongs to
the family of SPL or as DP binding
domain the transcription factors SPL 7
Estill SEMO noted does like really
simple model of the experiment based
regulation of copper corner status and
the copper deficiency SPO 7 up regulates
expression of copper uptake and the
transporters and also genes encoding
transporters which is possible for the
internal copper movement in a plant and
the second role is that SPO 7 up
regulate the so-called copper
reutilization system or we call it
copper economy system when plans try to
feed on their own reserves and just
metabolize they just get rid of less a
very abundant but on essential copper
protein and so delivered copper to much
more essential copper requiring
functions and so it is not surprised
that a spill 7 mutant of course it's
sensitive to low copper in the
environment and the point here that SPO
cell was the only transcription factor
which was known to regulate copper
homeostasis in vascular plants and so we
were very excited when a PhD student in
a lab ship a young she identified a
normal correspond to transcription
factor which we designated set one
copper deficiency youth transcription
factor one and of course the
bread-and-butter work writers have to
see whether you know if it's up
regulated it's copper regulated but
whether it has something to do with
regulating copper connectors we always
have to go down to the Newton and so
Jaffe
I like the mutant and she grows the
mutant in the presence of flow operand
what she found that under control
condition the mutant was looking pretty
much as a wild-type and here you can see
this is a mutant expressing the set1
genomic fragment so it's a complement a
complementary line but then under
corporate efficiency the mutant was
growing really poorly and also we
developed this korat export on mature
use which indicative of copper
deficiency and then the genomic fragment
can fully complement the mutant we also
found that this you know coppers
increased sensitivity to copper
deficiency as associated with the
decreased ability of the newton to take
up iron and move iron in a plant body so
for example here you can see that in the
root the fitment mutant has
significantly less copper than the
wild-type and it's pretty much true for
each tissue and also we analyzed flowers
because remember I mentioned that copper
was associated with somehow it was
always mentioned that copper is needed
for fertility and so they also analyzed
copper accumulation in flowers of the
mutant and headless and also what is
noticeable here that actually there was
some there was less seeds in a sink so
yeah and then next we decided to see
well is there a relationship between
this newly identified transcription
factor set 1 and the previously known
transcription factor still 7 and so our
rationale was that well if these 2
transcription factors they work in the
same pathway then in a double mutant we
should see something like a still 7 like
phenotype which are the smaller growth
under well under limited copper
condition but that actually not what
happened initially while the action it
was difficult for us to find the mutant
was so tiny I took every year well
really literally took a year you were
looking for it and that you know we had
to tell were in fine group and we found
it well but the problem was adamant and
eventually died so that
the reason the phenotype was seedlings
and seedling ability that it took us so
much time to understand that actually
that's an issue and which meant that the
pathway is much more complexed so that
will be previously thought but then we
were able to rescue this seedling
lethality of the mutant with high copper
so again what you see here different
blunt lines wild-type set 1s bill 7
single mutants and the double mutant so
the mutant the double mutant now growth
well growth up to the reproductive stage
well it's smaller but it actually has
the same amount of copper as wild-type
all right so that was already for us
interesting right well it's smaller but
has the same amount of copper but then
what we noticed that although the mutant
the seeding utility is rescued and the
mutant growth the double mutant grow
through the reproductive stage the
double mutant is fully infertile well is
90% infertile so what you see here again
and and this is at 50 micromolar proper
which is really high with high non-toxic
equality so basically you can see other
geo dives are doing quite well but the
double mutant you know it's important
it's this is just elongated car pool
really to cut really long story short we
were able to detect that that's due to
Poland defect so that double mutant
produces like 90% less fallen Poland and
then of the Poland produced a more than
20% of the Poland for Jews is enviable
so it's very very strong Poland
fertility defect but again this double
mutant has the same amount of copper as
other lines right and that was for us
very puzzling like what's happening
there right and of course you were
thinking well maybe there are a couple
of hypotheses one of the hypothesis may
be these two transcription factors they
coagulate
copper delivery to the specific flower
structures right that was other favorite
hypothesis although we could not exclude
the possibility that these are
transcription factors they can regress
so many other things in a plant and
maybe something to do with copper so but
we again we favored the first hypo
and so how do we do that and that's how
we turned again to XRF we thought we
have to really look where copper
localizes within the flower structures
and I want to emphasize it it was not
known before what we knew before what
the just copper is needed but we're
co-operators if at all the sepals is it
Unser's is it normal knew before it and
so at that time we already took
advantage from the fact that we have
synchrotron facility here at Cornell
so that's Cornell high-energy proton
sauce here Wilson lab and that little
hole okay
very convenient it just depending how
you go different routes budget
regardless why will it at most so their
postdoc in the lab do change here how
its engine they collaborated with the
wrong one and Arthur wall a chest and
together what we were able to find is
that actually the majority of opera if
you look at the flower and this is the
wild-type and what you see here is the
distribution the copper density the
majority of copper is really peaks at
the in amperes it also localizes it
Carlos but you know the majority is
still in amperes and then when you look
at the different Newton lines you can
see that well fit one is well it's
somewhat affected a still seven is more
affected but then the double of Newton
has barely detectable copper all right
then we also looked for other elements
you looked for iron and I mean it's a
long story while you look for iron but
it was very important enough to show
that it's not just so it's actually just
copper it's not iron and that's what we
see here that iron is almost no I mean
it's very it's not statistically
significant basically and so basically
what it allows us to show that copper
well first of all copper is localized in
answers and also in in Karpis and then
we can pinpoint that this pollen in
fertility defect of the double mutant is
actually associated with the inability
of the mutant to move copper into the
answers
all right and just to conclude this part
so basically it was known for for a
while that well flower development and
flower fertility is controlled by many
factors which include photo period and
hormone so using XRF you are first of
all able to identify which floral organs
contain winnows and also XRF allowed us
to put transition metals in this case
copper is very significant contributing
factor to plant fertility so where we're
going from here of course we are very
interested now to translate this
knowledge we gained in grow in in water
are a bit obsessed to crops right and so
via collaborating with mark so with mark
soros we are using meta population with
making population generated in mark's
lab with the hope to identify cutie else
which will sort of be associated with
copper delivery to answers fertility and
input yield of lead and what you see we
already started doing this work so what
you see here you are seeing florida off
to parental line and actually their
offsprings and what you're seeing that
two parental line they have different
they differ in accumulation of copper in
anthers and actually i know its identity
these two parental lines also differ in
annealed I mean mark can correct me if
I'm wrong but they and so it seems that
the the W 79 84 is low yielding variety
and it yet accumulate less copper in
answer and also what we see that there
is a segregation for copper accumulation
in answers and actually in all the
reproductive organs because this is
Karpis and in metal population so we
really hope that this this will lead us
somewhere we are also collaborating with
Susan McCool and we are trying to sort
of adopt this technology also to rise
and this is because semi-high throughput
so there so these are 15 mine in six
hours I'm talking about highfalutin
so these are seeds seeds of rice and
what it allows us to see in the
distribution of elements in in seed
tissues and the importance of a site
that I mentioned before the tribe is
really and all of the the majority of
cereal crop they have very low
concentration of Windows in grace but
rice is the worst and especially white
rice is the worse and the reason is that
the majority of winners especially such
as iron they accumulate in how in ll
layer and so the breeding should be and
all of them the goal would be to
actually to identify varieties that will
have either not you know and maybe think
and other elements not the other layer
and in the hull but actually moving iron
into the endosperm and so this is like
the first step forages of 14 after I
think 2000 lines which is that have been
generated in cereals lab and to conclude
overall this talk I hope I can sort of
convince you that XRF is imagining is a
really powerful tool one of the tools
that can help us to to infer the
function of genes in Mel Newton Khmer
studies and I really hope and we all
hope you this tool that it will help us
to breathe for better crops for safer
and more nutrient-dense crops and was
that I would like to acknowledge me that
members so Jaffe she was liking honest
pure science at one proper project did
you change here and how its engine
they're they're they're two people in
the lab for really pushing forward this
XRF study and I would like to thank our
collaborators at the war and wrong one
from chess Miguel from robust wholly
Center here at Cornell Marc Storace
thousand mark which Mariano Mariano and
Leone caution and of course the funding
and we have questions we have one
question
Oh or we can take it outside and thank
you very much for the attention
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu